welcome to one of the last talks
um my name is Thomas fan I'm a Staff
soft engineer at on-site Labs I'm also a
maintainer for scikit-learn which is a
machine learning library in Python
today's talk is about parallelism in
numerical python libraries it's a quite
a big scoping talk because this is a
these are all loaded words parallels is
a loaded word but we're gonna narrow the
scope a little and talk about a specific
piece of ovens
so
blaming parallelism I mean
cpu-based parallelism so no accelerator
is like gpus
um that's a totally different talk it's
big
big also I own I mean things that run on
your laptop or a single node so no
multi-known
um
um ideas in this talk except for like
two slides which I I will cover and um
with an emphasis on python this is how
python libraries now
paralyze their code like these are the
libraries you use today and how do they
take advantage of all the cores on a
computer because all our computers have
multiple Chords it's the thing in 2022.
so
a very high low overview of this talk is
we have two main ideas we have
configuration and implementation
configuration is how to how do you
control the library's views and as in
how do you control the
um
the number of cores uh Library uses so
that you could scale upper scale down
for a library you have so that's very
important for end user and there's also
implementation is how does these
libraries actually do it
okay so there's two worlds here and I'm
going to cover both of them
um but we'll start off with something
simple numpy numpy has some parallelism
and I'm going to start off with a demo
with comparing ad and magic
multiplication
so um how many here use numpy or no of
numpy cool we're in pi data I know I'm a
pi data right now
um I'm gonna show I'm gonna do a quick
demo on ADD and Metric location on the
top I have a keyboard notebook I'm using
numpy's cool new generated API here
decoded um a random Matrix of 50 000 to
10 000 array on the bottom you can see
that I have
um 10 cores on my machine this is on my
local machine here on the bottom it's
how much
it's um when the part of the Fall that
means my chords are being used all right
so it's it's it's
um monitoring my CPU
here I have a quick time it command with
empty.com and my question I want to ask
here is
who thinks that this will be parallel
this will take up all my chords
cool all right so that means that when I
run this you can see that it would just
use up one of the lines will light up
right so it's a single threaded
operation
the other one is mission location this
is it's it's basic addition with some
multiplication right it's not that too
much different from the position I'm
going to create a matrix here that's
compatible with X that I created before
and if I do this how many people think
that mission multiplication X and Y is
parallel
so yes so this is parallel it uses all
my cores and it's taking advantage of
all the computer in my machine
I I found when I first saw this I found
it surprising like when I first
encountered this API and um there are
many questions you want to ask when
encountering this and we're going to
cover all a bunch of them and as we
start off with one is numpy parallel
right there we saw that ad is not
parallel and
um major multiplication is turns out
numpipipe
um then algebra everything in numpy and
algebra is parallel and the way you
notice is go to the docs like the API
doesn't actually it's not explicit you
have to go to the docs and then algebra
any anything under this page is how so
that's how you know
next question is how is the algebra
implemented and this is um numpy itself
doesn't have these many other routines
it dynamically links to libraries like
blast
um to libraries that implement the blast
API like open blast mbkl which is
Intel's map kernel library or Bliss
which is another one
the thing about the
um and each one and the blast is a
stable API that it's it's a statement
API that defines an algebra routines
the question here is
um each one of these have different
performance characteristics the Intel
one could most likely favors the
intelligent views so depending on how
you which blast you have you it may have
different performance characteristics so
things have run fast on one on your
laptop may have different performance
characteristics than on a server
how do you how do you know which blood
they're using in numpy this is cool
Library called Dreadful CTL which you
could run this on a command line and
what this gives you is the configuration
and um if it's using open blast
um if it's backed by p-dres which we'll
get into later and how many threads is
using
if it's mko it'll give you something
like this it'll tell you that the mkl so
this is a quick way to diagnose which
Blast Your numpy is using
now how do I select which class I'm
using on counterforge it's easy you
could just switch by one of these
commands is many different
documentations and on Pipi it only stuck
with one you have P threads and it's
backed by open Open Glass
now
remember one of the key points is
configuration how to configure Matrix
notification for parallelism there's two
ways environmental variables and
vertical CTL
environmental variables this whole whole
system there's many flavors of this
depending on this open blast number
threads mkl numbers OMP numb threads
which if your back ends built on openmp
that's what you use and there's a quite
a bit you have to know of them there's a
lot of environmental problems
I find the easier approach is using
thread for TCL which is a python
approach to this so this you don't have
to you can see that here it's a context
manager you can see that I'm using I'm
saying glass you don't have to care
about mkl flat open blast it just does
it it understands which blast is loaded
and it configures it the correct way you
could do it as a context manager you
could also have a global one so
that's very useful tool
um a common question I think about is
how how would I paralyze that can I do
it there's many tools for this number
how many her number very cool Just in
Time compiler
um python
Pi torch uh I'm gonna show two of these
because cyton is a little I'm gonna show
number and high torch very quickly as a
quick demo
so how do I power that numbers is it
just in time color you write things in
Python you could use
um P range here you can see I use P
range here and I could decorate this
thing with parallel and this runs if I
run these bits of code you can see that
if I run this is not my information a
sum on the access one and if I run this
you can see that on the bottom it uses
all my cores and it's parallel
the fun one is so if you don't want to
implement your own ad the fun one is
and um pytorch has some has many
operations and the thing is
um you can see here that torch that adds
array here
um it doesn't make a copy it looks at
your numpy ray x is a numpy ray it looks
at
um calling Azure on the pi torch array
creates a pi python tensor and that is
just a view into the numpy and to the
underlying memory of the numpy right and
so no copy you could call some on it and
then you can return it back out as a
numpy array so if you want to stay in
nump Highland this is a quick way to
accelerate Sun if I run this code you
could see that high torch is power wash
by default which is a different
characteristic than Empire so how to
that's a very quick way to paralyze some
addition in this case
oh that's
it so we touched by torch python just
parallel by default as you saw
it's built on open black I mean oh I
mean openmp or mkl and it has
environment environmental variables for
configuration it also has a library
specific parameter called
torch.set numdread so you can set number
threads for pi torch
so you're going to see many different
patterns come up again when it comes to
configuration of these libraries
environmental variables there's some
Library um specific function for
derivatives
okay so as numpy uh
that's it and that's a different Empire
sci-fi
also has some parallelism
um it's more it does a little more it's
not only open blast it covers
um the algebra the Sci-Fi has its own in
algebra sci-fi also uses
multi-processing and multi-threading in
smarter smart ways and it has its own
custom C plus plus custom Red Bull for
other functions so it uses a broad range
of methods for parallelizing python
then algebra quick one same semantics at
numpy it a dynamically links to a blast
and all the same configurations we had
numpy is in sci-fi
multi-processing is a fun one it's
configured using the workers parameter
so it's at the call site and these are
the four functions that gives you that
does multi-processing yeah you have to
look at the code internally see how it
does but this is each of the four
functions so
why does these functions use
multi-processing and not like
multi-threading well it's for example
brute optimize accepts a user function
called func over here
here bunk so you don't know if a user
releases the girl or not so the safest
way that the what the way you know for
sure that you can Palace this code is to
use multi-processing because
multiprocessing spawns multiple
processes that host has its own so this
works around the problem of um function
not
um okay well it still need to hold on to
the guild so this is why this
multi-processing so multi-processing if
you're not sure if the function you're
trying to move to paralyze reduce the
gearbox
on the other hand
there is
multi-threading in sci-fi this is all in
the spatial trees
um KD trees specifically also configured
using workers parameter and this is
using multi-threading
and the reason why this could be used
use multi-threading is because the
routines that we're trying
um
that the spacious trees are trying to
paralyze in the coin method is written
in C plus plus which releases to kill so
when the Gill is released you could run
multi-threaded and which and since
there's no since all the threats release
the kill they can run an account and
that is why this is
I cover that here but um these are more
that those are the big overarching ideas
about multi-processing multi-threading
just a few bits more here
um about shared memory and which we'll
cover in the later slide
um and in general multi-process you have
to think more about start methods
multi-threading this there's one way to
think about it but multi-threading you
need to think about the guild because if
you need to make sure the things you're
paralyzing reasons to go and a lot of
things do like numpy usually be this is
the girl
so but you have to be sure of this
though when doing when using
multi-threading
so for the Sci-Fi
um
there's also thinks about shared memory
which how
um where a multi-processing you have to
pass memory around which I'll get into
in another bit
okay
sci-fi also has C plus plus
um using bread pools and with its own
custom P threads and this is very
focused on it's it's fft module and it's
configured using workers just like
everything else
um this is residency plus plus so it
could use native threads for probably
Vision so
um one one question to ask here is
why is it using p threads and not
another like Dave threading layer like
openmp this is
um an issue in sci-fi that this question
was asked on an issue and like When
developing fft
um
their openmp has
interesting little issues when you have
um
period
um for example G new openmp is not
folksafe there's a
that then so it doesn't work well for
one of the start methods in
multi-processing
um
but oh and VM openmp it's fine so like
it's kind of the story is kind of
um it doesn't work well all the time and
there's um openmp libraries running
um simultaneously
may not be compatible with each other
and so this is we're getting into this a
little more in the future but this is
the general idea of why
um scipy uses P threads and not openmp
and openmp is another dreading library
that one can use
okay
pandas
um how many people use pandas here
all right
pandas
Paolo maybe question mark
um how many um there is a little bit of
parallelism in pandas and I'm gonna
it has to do with how you could have a
number engine or Panda and these are in
the group by in Bowling allegations and
it could paralyze over data frame if you
set the right keyword parameter so I
think this is um interesting enough to
have a demo about pandas and parallelism
all right
so here pandas I'm creating a data set
of 1 million by 10 columns
so this is my data set it's
and I'm going to create a data frame and
then I'm going to do a rolling window
all right
I'm straightforward pandas and I'm going
to call the means I'm going to find the
mean of the wrong windows so if I time
it for row.me you can see that one bar
would light up on the bottom say one bar
at a time so this is a single single
core
if you want to paralyze this
it's the same claw but you pass in a
little more arguments you pass an engine
angle number and engine keyword
arguments equal the parallel um and the
arguments with dictionary or probably
true and if I run this
you can see that it will use all my
chords
so I don't I just has a few arguments
and it and it runs faster than above
so this is a quick way to paralyze your
python your panda is called
for the functions that support it
all right so pandas
um and that's it and that's the only way
that's it that's how I found that's
that's how Canada's being followed
um they're looking into thinking about
integrating openmp or P threads into the
library so it's parallel by default but
that is not in
um canvas now
speaking of number
there's this fun Library called umap how
many from a umap it's a fun Dimension
reduction Library
um it's um it's all Python and it uses
the number decorator to paralyze all the
code so that's a quick fun mention on
your map
so I'm born a number a few times here so
configuration for number so there's many
libraries that use number as a thing as
a way to paralyze their code and the way
to configure number in all these cases
is that they have environmental variable
and they have a height and a python API
as well number that's not number X
um it also has many backing layers it
has openmp as a Threading layer it has
Intel threading Building Blocks tpps
login area and it also has its own
Customs repo if you don't have the other
now
there there are some concern
considerations when using number and
number has thought about this stuff
where where when you're using
um certain types of threading layers it
may not be compatible with how python
parallel or certain python parallel
libraries and there's different flavors
of multi-processing as you saw before
and multi-threading
not get too much into here but um in the
numpy documentation they cover this
through and through so you have to be
careful with how number
um
for example
um when you run gnew openmp and you Fork
number will catch that and be like no
you can't do this because
um it will stall indefinitely so number
one cash generates error so that you as
a user don't have to worry about it and
then I like this approach for number
all right so I touched a number here so
and I touched on like C plus plus code
and This falls into two big camps of
parallelization there's ahead of time
compiled compilation and number which is
just in time compilation so like
languages like C plus plus Fortran Ross
python you have to compile it first and
you have to if if you want a power
logical you have to choose mostly choose
between these two
um adult time polling means that you
have it's hard to build you have to
actually compile your code so you have
to set up a whole build system to
distribute ahead of time to power code
but the nice thing about this is there's
less requirements and runtime you I
usually with just install runs
um number is nice because it's the
source code is python like as we saw
before you can just write normal python
add the number director parallel and but
the downside is that it requires the
power at runtime because it's just in
time compiled so
those are the the options you have the
way as it ashes here number does have
ahead of time compilation it's just not
as full featured as just-in-time
population so it
so that's um these two things
I mentioned rust here
so what's a fun Library that's new in
Python that uses rice
haulers all right Polaris is parallel by
default you run any if you compute what
colors it just uses all your cores the
way it implements parallelism it uses a
rust Library called rayon which
underneath the cover uses P threatens
and um the way you can figure this is
Polaris Max num drives so
colors
okay
so I can learn
has parallelism
um it has many fun forms of it
like scipy it uses multi-threading
multi-processing but with a fun Loki
backend
it has openmp routines which is parallel
by default
it also inherits all the blast semantics
from numpy and sci-fi because numpy and
sci-fi are dependencies as I can learn
so if your library that uses number and
sci-fi you also inherit all the
parallelism aspects of using blast which
is all the linear algebra operations
okay what are you threading
um multi-threading is used in famous
season around forests
um
and this works because Brandon Forest is
written in cython and the cython code
releases the Gill which means we could
do multi-threading so that's what you're
threatening
um the configuration is used and jobs
and that configures it
okay multi-processing
um it's in our uh fantasy in our
parameter searching hybrid primary
searching
estimators a fun new one is having with
search TV which is our successive having
implementation I recommend looking into
that and um the configuration here is
you also end jobs the reason why this
multi-processing is because you don't
know that the machine learning model
you're using will release the gear or
not so you have to stuck with
multi-processing here
so multi-processing uses something
feels like to learn engine developers
developed called Loki which is python
multi-processing
but
it's better
right it has some certain features like
um if the text when worker process fails
and then raise an error in Python it
reuses pools of workers it's it responds
by default to avoid the whole um openmp
doesn't work when multi-processing Forks
so it tries to make it so that it's
easier to use multifacets
um
um as we saw before as I said before
about memory when using multiprocessing
you have your main worker which is it
could be your notebook it has data and
then spawning all these workers to do
some computation and this by default
um the member the data is pickled and
copied onto the workers you do
computation and that may be that blocks
the if this is on one computer it will
just it will use up your RAM basically
what Cyclone does
is that it's
writes your data to this as read only
and this is a very common Paradigm with
other Frameworks that do most processing
it it writes to this
um as read-only data and your workers
just references that data and then
computes
which means that you don't that the
workers just reference one single um
references data which means it doesn't
copy it
um to each work and this is using memory
mapping
um that is not mapping so yeah so when
using multi-processing you have to think
about the memory and this is um that
solution that cycling came up with
um can we um questions then yeah
okay we covered openmp as well and
secondary has openmp which is powered by
default
um I want to highlight history and
Grading boosting which is cycling
implementation it's uses openmp
um recently we have care rights
reductions Paradise distance reductions
that use openmp by default and
um
many many estimators and machine
learning mileage uses so there's Disney
there's candy Rivers there's a lot and
the way you can figure this since it's
open MP base is um OMP threads or direct
booster
okay so we're quite a quite a bit here
with a multi-threading multi-processing
multi-processing with Loki we did openmp
uh now what if we combine gnome like
what if we do multi-processing in openmp
um
it's like uh Cyclone has developed um
its back-end uses job limb and it
automatically detects
um how many workers responding and then
configures the native library to use the
number of correct number threads so that
you do not run into oversubscription
um this is demonstrating I demonstrate
I've wanted to create a demo on this but
as you can see
um in my in the slides it takes too long
for those subscribe parts so as a quick
example here the classifier is system
grading boosting which uses openmp and
having Blitzer CV which uses Loki so
this is nested parallelism when there's
parallelism in the estimator itself and
there's parallelism when searching
um and I'm going to measure the time
with it
and this is my results very quickly I'm
going to focus on certain items you can
see that n jobs equal one and OMP
um threads unset which is the default
most people don't set OMP numb threads
you can see that it takes 42 seconds and
that's exactly the same as setting it to
16. so by default if you use one job so
no work is being spawned it uses all
your cores 42 seconds it's the same
thing it's not setting it now if you do
nw16
um and you unset it you can see that it
performs with eight seconds which is the
same as setting OMP thread number
threads to a second so it will
automatically set the number of threads
equal to
um in this case um 16 divided by 16
because in this machine I had 16 cores
running and at the end
you could also see that um I try to run
this with 16 n drops 16 and OMP numb3rd
16. um in this case jobless doesn't do
anything because you manually set it to
16 so it's going to obey it in this case
I try to I run it for 10 minutes and I
gave up because it didn't work it didn't
end
so this is something to think about when
thinking about oversubscription
so this is a problem and
libraries like desk
they by default when this when working
with us
it sets all the environment about what
you want so when that spawns its workers
it doesn't it just everything would be
single threaded mode and that's how it
avoids the oversection problem
um how many of you um have heard of Ray
it's a fun New Library
does the same thing it will also set all
these native libraries you want to
single thread it because it has its own
um way of Performing
um sort of spotting workers to do remote
process so in both of these cases it
um configures the native library to be
single dreaded
now
when we went there's a lot of bits here
and the question I when thinking about
this talk and thinking about parallels
in Python is is there an issue with
or the current state of python and
parallelism
uh
baby like
I
as I said before
um when using multiple parallel apis
things
come up even if you use multiple native
thread libraries like
um open blasts when using open blast
with p-dres and open blasts and then you
have openmp code
things may stall
Maybe
um if you're if you're using two openmp
runtimes which means openmp with compile
with lvm and openmp compiler with gnu
things may be bad
um and also if you have two open blast
president which is
how many
um you commonly see this when you
install cycle and Empire pipei they both
ship with their own openmp open blast
and um
um this led to your performance
regression and Mac laptops machines but
um sci-fi set an enventor variable to
patch things over which is not great you
have the library sets environment
available to perform to
um stop a performance regression so you
can read more I wrote a lot about this
fun stuff in this design document
also when combining native libraries uh
like like using open p-dreth and openp
combined with multi-processing in Python
all sorts of fun issues there's like
every library has its own documentation
about this so like there's like pullers
there's numbers like learn pandas
they're like oh if you use python
multi-processing
and use our user Library
things may break
but watch out
so that's fun
I like how a number handles it like I
said before where it tried to detect
these edge cases and raise an error so
that a user could
probably handle it because um if a lot
of these times the issue is it stalls
and you have no no recourse so besides
reading the documentation so it's nice
if the library detects these and just
raises the same error
okay the second issue is um hold up by
default question mark
this is a question I'm thinking about
and if this should be the case what I
mean by problem default is some
libraries are parallel by default like
Pi torch or um folders which uses our
chords by default and the other sides
are single threaded by default which is
pendants and there are some things like
in the middle which is sometimes
parallel sometimes not so what should be
default do you want a machine that uses
all the chords by default when running
or single threaded so this is two
aspects of this
um if you're on the com on your laptop
and you want to go and you're doing like
something big analysis on your laptop
you do you do want to use all your cores
and you want to get the most performance
out of your laptop so that's an argument
for our course
single core
people that are putting things in
production like it's much easier reason
about if the programs if your program is
single to edit and then you configure it
if you follow
rather than having power by default
because you can you may have your own
way of piloting your code and then it
runs into the problem with python also
powers
so I'm open to discuss this
um in detail with everyone with who has
opinion on this matter
okay
so
lots of stuff here but the overarching
themes whereas configuration
implementation
for configuration you have environmental
variables we have went through a whole
like skill of them there's OMP numb
threads there's mko numbers and Etc
there's libraries that have python that
have a python API to set it globally
like Pi torch
um there's also contact managers like
Dreadful CTO that sets it locally in
Python and there's also call side
parameters like workers and jobs
there's a lot
um maybe an issue
maybe like it would be nice if there's a
unified way to do this
but this is so if you're if you're new
to a library you have to know and like
go to the documentation so you get it
get these just get this information on
how to configure your library
that's on the configuration side on the
implementation side we there's many ways
to do it and you can write your your
um your provided in C right in C plus
number Russ any language you want
the underlying mechanisms is still
um if you use multi-processing from
Python and mostly threading from python
or underneath it could use native
threads so but so another implementation
uses one of these
um parallel mechanisms but
um the language may change
so
that's implementation
Okay so
that's a very fast overview on
parallelism and numerical python
libraries
um all this all the materials available
on GitHub and
hope everyone here now gets a good
glimpse of how all these libraries try
to run faster
on your missions thank you for coming
back
[Applause]
awesome uh any questions
actually I have a I have I'll start with
since I have the mic
um it's kind of a specific question but
in
linear so in psychic learn like linear
regression and ridge regression are
those parallel by default since they use
like matrix multiplication
I think okay so
I'm like scanning through the code base
in my head so give me a second
um
during fits it uses B squared which from
sci-fi or it uses B squared which is not
parallel by default but during
um uh prediction time yes they use
Mission vocation so it's parallel of
turn prediction time but not during this
time
oh yeah
yeah so I'm kind of new to this and I
wonder what is the difference between
multi-processing and multi-threading
oh um I I kind of really quick visit
went through that one slide that covers
it but um
uh multi-processes spawns multiple
python process multiple interpreters and
which has their own Guild
um they're usually compared to
multi-threading they're slower to spot
like it's slow to spawn different
processes while dreading it's quicker to
spawn and
that's
there's also other ones
um and multi in multi-trading you have
it is multi-driving python code you have
to for numerical Computing you have to
make sure that your things you're
motivating reduces the game
multi-threading has shared memory
there's there's a quite a few
differences and they but for this talk I
try to push that you use
multi-processing if the python functions
are paralyzing over does not release the
go and then you can easily processing to
colonize it but and if the thing you're
paralyzing over does not
um does release the kill then you can
use more contract that's kind of the
talking point I was trying to push
um
yeah first off thank you a quick
question about do you know approximately
what version of scikit uh started
supporting mem mapping when
working processes
it's not a pop quiz or anything but it
wasn't always like that right yes oh no
I would go through the history of this
it's probably like an 0.2
okay 0.22 ish
good it's but this is um this is a
default from Diablo and even if you have
an old Cyclone version and you saw a new
version of Javelin I think this default
turns just turns on do you have a
follow-up question on this no a separate
follow-up whether when you were
evaluating different strategies did you
consider including like using a context
manager with a desk back end or is that
not a fair comparison because the
scheduler is kind of intervening oh
um
all right
it's a question about
can you distribute the tasks using that
with contact manager well just thinking
about like some of the scikit stuff that
you went through
um you know you can start like a local
desk uh cluster and use the context
manager set that to the back end and
then have some scikit code in there
running and you know that would be
another option but I was wondering if
you omitted it because it's not Apples
to Apples comparison I see
um I I didn't want to put okay so for
contact you could the most popular one
is um you could run
um instead Java uses Loki by default but
you can switch that with task and then
run a Das cluster and run using bass
technology code and I didn't put it in
to simplify the talk I don't want to
cover that
too much
any more questions
all right
should I have like a strong opinion on
blasts or openmp uh like if
I just got a new computer do I install
one or how do I think about this too you
use the default and hopefully I don't
want to use anything too much about this
um it's
um so use the default provided by your
installer because install is installed
different classes and and if you're the
thing I would the thing I would be
concerned with is performance like um
like there was a time where in
um the Intel mko didn't run as well on
AMD and that in that case
um you may want to switch out your blast
because level performs but besides that
we I hope that the default would be fine
and I usually won't worry about it
another question
[Applause]
no I did oh you do okay yeah
um so Thomas you showed us that uh sort
of the apis for configuring the amount
of uh against workers or some sort of
all over the place some people call IT
workers some people call it something
else do you think that uh like setting
like saying the parameter name should be
workers is doing it at the right level
or should there be like a workers and a
threads or processes
this is this is opinion yeah I I've
heard many arguments on this I I do as a
new if I was a newcomer I would want
some unified way to do this like there's
I think I I just I showed like seven
different ways to do environmental
variables like Cosi parameters
there's two or more in other libraries
obviously you have their own call site
like I do wish like workers would be the
parameter reused
um my high like if I really wanted like
I would wish there's a numerical python
numb threads or something and then like
every numerical python Library just uses
that and then to configure it it would
be nice and so you don't have to worry
about which back-end you use so that a
user would just configure one variable
and it would just work for all the
libraries that'd be very nice and I
still wish for that face a chance to
happen but it's a lot of um you have to
gather support from all these others
well let's do one more question
yes there is there a good way to figure
out whether or not a function releases
the Gill oh
I don't think so
okay that's the fun way the fun way is
to um
uh create a multi processing pool and
then run it and see what happens
so it's basically just trial and error
okay I mean oh you could um you could
and you could um use one of the
inspection there's a village Tracer and
you can run Bridge tracer on it and then
see if it reduces the goal
there but that's
there's no use there's no it'd be nice
to create that Library by the way like
that's my function releases the girl so
good idea
but it doesn't exist right now
oh that was awesome let's thank our
speaker again
[Applause]